bonjour oui enfin on est plus en jouant
des plantes c'est plutôt bon soir ouais
bon soir c'est juste que comme on
revient de toujours ce 2 mars je suis
encore en plein jet lag interplanétaire
d'ailleurs ça me fait penser on a une
surprise pour vous oui bon angle à
cordes c'est pas le texte d'origine sur
les paillons la photoshopée mais le
reste est bien réelle sauf qu'on n'était
pas réellement sur mars mais dans le
désert de l'utah
alors pour tout vous dire il ya quelques
mois encore cette photo aurait été de la
science-fiction flanc c'est moi on n'a
pas le même âge n'a pas le même parcours
moi j'habite et même pas en france et on
ne s'étaient jamais rencontrés avant
d'aller ces journées ensemble dans ce
paysage extraterrestres et pourtant on y
était bien on est restés là bas deux
semaines pour y simuler un séjour sur
mars dans une mission dite analogues
alors ce genre de mission est très
importante pour le futur de
l'exploration habitée
parce qu'elle permet de tester des
technologies et des pros et des
procédures dans un environnement quasi
réel et d'ailleurs je pense que on a une
photo de notre photo on a eu photo ces
missions oui ça ressemble vraiment à
mars
et ces messieurs analogues sont aussi
très importantes pour pour tester la
psychologie et étudier la performance et
la cohésion des équipes qui évoluent en
environnements confinés comme ça pendant
de longs mois la probabilité pour vous
compte pour qu'on se rejoignent toutes
les deux dans ce genre de mission
étaient vraiment très faibles
moi je suis ingénieur en aérospatiale et
doctorante en génie des procédés
biologiques mais les travaux de
recherches se concentrent sur la pousse
de légumes de plantes comestibles dans
l'espace que les astronautes pourront
consommer lorsqu'ils passeront des mois
voire des années à des millions de
kilomètres de la terre sans aucune
possibilité dans la vitime ans dans un
autre registre
j'ai aussi déjà un peu donné de ma
personne pour l'exploration spatiale
puisque l'année dernière j'ai été le
cobaye avec cinq autres personnes pour
une étude psychologique de la nasa qui a
duré quatre mois et c'était aussi lors
d'une mission analogue comme vous le
pouvez voir sur cette photo je suis
auteure et comédienne
j'aime raconter des histoires quelle que
soit la manière quel que soit le support
et quel que soit évidemment leur nature
même si bien sûr mes préférés porte sur
les sciences et le spatial et j'écris de
la fiction à mes heures perdues mais ma
principale activité consiste à faire de
la vulgarisation scientifique soit dans
l'immédiat soit sur internet sur youtube
en ligne partout mais si j'aime raconter
des histoires j'aime encore plus les
vivres et c'est pour ça que je me suis
portée candidate à un projet qui
s'appelle marc swan et qui envisage
sérieusement d'établir une base humaine
permanente sur la planète mars
donc a priori nos univers n'ont rien en
commun
pourtant on partage une même passion les
l'espace chaque atome qui composent
cette pièce les meubles qu'elle contient
l'air qu'on y respire et jusqu'à nos
propres corps ont tous été formés dans
des étoiles
il ya des milliards d'années à l'échelle
atomique nous venons tous de l'espace à
l'échelle macroscopique nous vivons tous
sur un même vaisseau spatial qu'on
appelle la terre et pourtant lorsqu'un
enfant rêve de devenir astronaute
on lui dit que c'est impossible quand
j'étais petite je voulais visiter tous
les mondes de l'univers ce que je
voulais aller voir partout dans l'espace
en fait
et puis je voulais aller voir partout
dans le temps aussi alors je me suis dit
que je deviendrais comédienne parce que
comme ça je pourrais voyager dans le
temps en interprétant des personnages du
passé vers le futur est aujourd'hui en
fait je me rends compte que c'est parce
que j'ai jamais vraiment été satisfaites
du monde dans lequel je vis et
d'ailleurs je suis fasciné par les films
catastrophe
vous savez ce genre de film ou le monde
tel qu'on le connaît et disparaît bon
bah si j'ai autant besoin d'en voir
c'est parce que ça agit sur moi comme
une catharsis
c'est c'est vraiment ça me libère et moi
quand j'étais petite je voulais devenir
astronaute
c'est je peux pas levé les yeux vers le
ciel la nuit sans rêver que me
promènerai un jour avec ma fille c'est
d'ailleurs c'est ce que je répondais à
chaque rentrée scolaire quand me
demander ce que je voulais faire plus
tard quand je serai grand
jusqu'au jour où au collège on m'a fait
comprendre que répondent astronautes à
mon âge ça ne faisait plus très sérieux
donc j'ai arrêté d'écrire astronautes
sur ma petite feuille mais je marquais
ne sais pas seuls mes proches mais
vraiment très très proche avait vraiment
ce que je voulais faire même s'ils vont
céder venir sujet un peu tabou de parler
plus trop j'ai gardé ma passion pour
l'espace pour moi aussi parce que on
prenait pas au sérieux non plus et on se
moquait de moi également quand je disais
que je voulais être comédienne et
écrivain néanmoins c'était plus terre à
terre que visiter tous les mondes de
l'univers donc j'ai insisté au moins sur
ça alors moi on m'a déconseillé de
m'orienter vers la l'astrophysique si je
voulais devenir astronaute
alors quand j'étais en cinquième j'en ai
parlé à mes professeurs qui m'a
gentiment répondu que mon
l'astrophysique c'est réservé à des gens
qui sont brillants voir surdoué et que
malheureusement ce n'était pas mon cas
moi qui suis juste normal et donc j'ai
renoncé à étudier l'astrophysique
mais j'ai quand même après ça pendant
sept ans et des stages astronomie tous
les étés non j'ai passé un bac
littéraire
j'ai fait une école de comédie musicale
et j'ai décroché un diplôme de
journalisme et pendant longtemps livre
eh ben j'écrivais des histoires dans
lesquelles l'héroïne avait toujours un
lien avec l'espace
je lisais des montagnes en dc
scientifique et j'allais voir des
conférences de vulgarisation mais
toujours sans en parler à personne en
cachette
c'est vrai mais en fait toutes ces
années ça m'a permis d'accumuler des
connaissances et des connaissances et de
nouer des relations dans des domaines
qui a priori n'est pas du tout mais du
tout sur mon chemin
et ben moi je me suis orienté vers
l'école des mines de nancy parce que ça
me fermer aucune porte et ça permettait
de dans l'un des mâts carrière par le
spatial comme comme je le voulais grâce
à mon choix département grâce à mon
choix de stages notamment celui l agence
spatiale européenne et grâce à mon choix
de double diplôme en génie aérospatial
alors j'ai commencé ma carrière sur
france 5 dans une émission qui
s'appelait le grand au bizet voilà où
j'étais à la fois community manager co
animatrice et comédienne parce qu'en
parallèle à l'émission on faisait une
une web série pour raconter le quotidien
de la production et j'aurais jamais eu
jamais eu ce poste si je n'avais pas à
la fois eu mon double cursus
journalistique et artistique
s'il n'avait pas tenu un blog personnel
depuis des années et si je n'avais pas
écrit et réalisé un cv vidéo qui avait
fait le buzz deux ans auparavant
donc c'est déjà beaucoup beaucoup de
travail pour arriver jusque là et
j'étais la plus heureuse de tout
l'univers jusqu'au jour où l'émission
s'est arrêtée prématurément en plein
milieu de la saison et là je vous avoue
j'étais un petit peu déprimé donc j'ai
cherché quelque chose de créatif à faire
pour pour penser à autre chose mais je
savais pas quoi
alors du coup je me suis refait le film
à l'envers et je me suis souvenu de la
toute première émission qu'on avait fait
c'était le 28 octobre 2011 et cette date
là était une des dates de sang du monde
dans un des calendriers mayas bahia et
du coup on en a fait le thème principal
de l'émission qui veut que j'avais adoré
vous imaginez bien et pour venir nous en
parler on avait invité un astrophysicien
christophe galfard voilà je pense que
j'aurais été moins impressionnée si on
m'avait présenté brad pitt environ il y
avait un illustrateur sur le plateau a
acquis les internautes avaient demandé
de dessiner un pédalo rameurs pour aller
sur la lune est notre invité alexandre
astier avait fait un sketch sur la
physique quantique
quelques mois plus tôt que j'avais adoré
et je me suis souvenu tout ça est en
fait je me suis dit bon c'est ridicule
parce que cette émission j'ai ses rangs
les rencontres que j'ai pu faire pendant
cette émission je les ai apprécié
toujours en cachette secrètement comme
si c'était une honte et je me suis dit
c'est ridicule il faut arrêter de se
cacher je vais je vais je vais je vais
voilà crier au monde entier que ma
passion c'est l'espace et c'est la
physique et donc j'ai décidé de créer
l'univers en 30 compte sur twitter
j ai pas je partage je partage
l'actualité des sciences et de
l'exploration spatiale
j'ai fait un billet sur mon blog pour
expliquer ma démarche et c'est comme ça
que tout a commencé
voilà donc florence travailler dans les
métiers en france
moi dans la recherche à l'étranger donc
ont évolué dans des sphères totalement
distincts
ouais jusqu'au jour on s'est rencontré
sur adopte une fusée points comme je le
leur dis pas ça c'est tout on s'est
rencontrés on fait rencontrer lors d'un
concours international pour gagner une
place pour un vol touristique un vol
spatial touristique d'une valeur de 100
mille dollars
autant pour moi donc l'une des épreuves
consistaient à s'inscrire en ligne et a
récolté le plus de voix du public et
c'est là qu'on s'est croisés on était
toutes les deux dans le top 10 en france
improbable n'est ce pas mais pas
impossible la preuve alors bon on n'a
pas gagné le vol mais ça a débouché sur
des échanges de mails d'abord et puis
ensuite quelques mois plus tard ça nous
a permis de rencontrer en vrai dans la
vraie vie
au moment de partir sur mars oui enfin
c'est en mars dans l'utah oui sur mars
dans l'utah en tout cas ce qu'il ya de
commun nos deux parcours c'est que ni
l'une ni l'autre on nous a prise au
sérieux quand on a exprimé le désir
d'aller dans l'espace on nous a fait
comprendre à toutes les deux que c'était
impossible mais est-ce que ça l'est
vraiment à ce jour plus de 550 personnes
hommes et femmes sont devenus
astronautes
bon c'est peu dans le monde entier c'est
vrai que c'est peu mais c'est pas
impossible
c'est juste un probable ça veut dire que
la probabilité est faible mais qu'elle
n'est pas nul elle existe
savez-vous quelle était la probabilité
pour que l'être humain apparaissent sur
terre l'ars a fallu que le nuage de
poussières autour du soleil nouveau-né
s'organisant planète que parmi celles ci
l'une d'elles soit rocheuse située pas
trop près du soleil mais pas trop loin
non plus il a ensuite fallu qu'un corps
de la taille de mars environ entre en
collision avec cette proto terre pour
former la lune et il aura fallu que des
géantes gazeuses ceux situés non loin de
là pour la protéger et ensuite sur cette
terre il aura fallu qu l'atmosphère
secret culte etc tonique des plaques se
met en route et que des océans
paraissent tout ça pour que pour que la
vie puisse apparaître et cette vie
ensuite évolué est elle apparue fin elle
a apparu dans des conditions même
aujourd'hui qui restent qui reste le
flou on sait pas exactement
malgré de nombreuses théories elle a
évolué elle a subi cinq extinctions de
masse
du le plus souvent à des phénomènes
aléatoires qui sont venus éradiquer les
espèces dominantes précédente pour
laisser sa chance à un petit mammifère
d'évoluer jusqu'à devenir un hominidé et
ensuite il aura fallu des conditions
précises pour que cet hominidé évolué
jusqu'à devenir no homo sapiens sapiens
un être humain si l'un ou l'autre de ces
événements n'étaient pas n'était pas
advenu mais c'était qu'un détail on
serait pas là aujourd'hui pour en parler
et pourtant nous sommes ici tous ont ce
point précis de l'espace temps qu'elle
était la probabilité pour que ça arrive
elle était infiniment faible et pourtant
nous sommes dans probabilité il ya deux
choses il ya la possibilité
eyal aléatoire il n'y a aucune raison
valable de ne pas tenter de mener à bien
un projet s'il ya une chance qu'il
réussisse même si cette chance est un
film mais plus la chance qu'ils
réussissent est un film plus il faut
contrer le facteur aléatoire et pour
combattre le hasard il faut tout mettre
en oeuvre pour aller dans la direction
voulue et pour ça on a deux outils à
notre disposition le travail et
l'énergie
c'est ce que je m'efforce de mettre en
oeuvre dans ma vie pour être le plus
près possible le jour où l'occasion de
devenir à son hôte se présentera si elle
se présente un jour alors il n'y a pas
de formation pour devenir astronaute
mais on ne naît pas à son autre non plus
un des meilleurs moyens que l'on peut
trouver pour se préparer c'est
d'éplucher le cv des astronautes
actuelle et on y retrouve de nombreux
points communs une formation de pilote
de chasse ou de pilote de ligne un
doctorat un brevet de pilote privé de la
plongée des sauts en parachute
les activités sportives soutenu et de
nombreuses langues parlées
les gens passent ma formation et mes
activités de ne permettent pas de
postuler à un recrutement d'astronautes
classique dans l'immédiat mais quand le
projet mars one a lancé un appel à
candidatures pour un aller simple vers
mars en ouvrant les candidatures
absolument tous les profils bas j'ai
tenté ma chance et j'ai je suis pas allé
jusqu'au bout du processus de sélection
mais quelle était la probabilité pour
que je fasse déjà partie du 0,3 pour
cent des candidats qui sont arrivés
jusqu'au second tour
elle était faible cette probabilité mais
j'y suis arrivé
j'y suis arrivé parce que j'ai travaillé
ma candidature d'arrache-pied et parce
que je me suis donné à fond dans toutes
les étapes du processus de sélection et
cette aventure d'un an m'a permis de
renforcer ma position d'ambassadrice
communicante sur l'exploration spatiale
et sur les sciences de l'univers donc
lors de la dernière sélection dassault
note en 2008 dans son auto européen
en tout cas j'ai eu plus de huit mille
candidatures pour six classes
ça fait moins d'une chance sur mille
improbable n'est ce pas mais pas
impossible donc moi on est plus sur le
cv des astronautes européens et
américains ce que j'ai trouvé dedans
c'était des choses que j'avais toujours
eu envie de faire et que voulait
absolument faire avant de moyens et donc
ce que je veux j'ai fait c'est j'ai
changé le timing je me suis dit je
n'avais pas toute ma vie pour les
réaliser mais j'avais jusqu'à la
prochaine sélection d'astronautes
européens
donc jusqu'à présent j'ai eu la chance
de piloter un avion au dessus de chicago
d'explorer les fonds marins de hawaï de
courir le marathon de brême de calcul et
d écoulement turbulent et les
trajectoires interplanétaire de pouvoir
m'exprimer correctement en cinq langues
d'avoir commencé une thèse mais surtout
d'être allé trois fois sur mars et enfin
la simulation
oui aussi mais n'empêche que tout ça
représente beaucoup de travail et
d'efforts de sacrifices et enfin si je
m'efforce de de combattre le facteur
aléatoire et et de combattre
l'improbable c'est pour faire basculer
le curseur de l'impossible vers le
possible avec mon bac littéraire est ma
formation de comédienne qu'elle était la
probabilité pour que je puisse apporter
ma contribution au milieu du spatial
elle était faible encore une fois
probabilité
donc il a fallu que je travaille mais
aussi beaucoup pour faire également
basculer le curseur de l'impossible vers
le possible
donc du coup en plus de l'univers en 30
compte sur twitter j'ai créé un podcast
qui m'a permis de devenir chroniqueuse
scientifique dans la tête au carré sur
france inter je fais des bus des vidéos
de vulgarisation scientifique sur
youtube et depuis et ben voila je côtoie
des astronautes
j'ai interviewé
des scientifiques de renom j'ai fait un
vol en apesanteur et j'ai participé à
une mission de simulation martienne donc
le travail de florence est très
important pour le futur de l'exploration
spatiale
puisqu'il permet d'impliquer le grand
public et de le tenir informé des
dernières avancées de ce domaine et
c'est crucial en crucial de relayer ce
genre d'information pour les politiques
et pour le grand public pour leur
montrer que le spatial s'est passé
quelque chose d'inutile et l'abstrait
pour une bande d'illuminés mais que ça
vient des applications réelles sur terre
et que ça contribue à rendre notre monde
meilleur
alors j'ai raconté notre mission sur
mars à la fois de manière journalistique
mais aussi par le biais de vidéos en
m'exprimant plus comme auteure et
comédienne et et tout ça et pourquoi
j'ai fait tout ça d'ailleurs jamais mais
je sais partager comme ça mais tout à
fait pour le grand public déjà mais j'ai
pas fait seulement ça c'est que j'ai
participé également aux expériences
scientifiques que l'uci et les autres
membres d'équipage avaient mené sur
place et dont les données serviront aux
futures d'exploration habitées vers mars
et ben voilà la chance pour que j'aille
visiter un autre monde que la terre est
quasi nul mais tout est dans le quasi je
sauverai pas le monde à moi tout seul
mais en équipe
j'ai déjà contribué à le faire et je ne
compte pas m'arrêter là donc si on est
ensemble aujourd'hui pour témoigner de
notre travail de notre effort nos
efforts pour contrer l'improbable est
allé au delà du possible pour montrer
que même si individuellement on n'arrive
pas à aller dans l'espace
on aura au moins contribuer à l'effort
commun d'envoyer des êtres humains sur
mars
merci